and while we're on the subject of policy
we obviously can't talk about policy
right now without discussing u.s.
foreign policy which Donald Trump
unfortunately laid out quite
disturbingly in a tweet this past
weekend if Iran wants to fight that will
be the official end of Iran never
threaten the United States again that
was a tweet sent on May 19th at 3:25
p.m. eastern time if Iran wants to fight
that will be the official end of Iran
there's a reason the president tweeted
this out and the reason is so stupid I
almost don't want to say it but I kind
of have to to tell the story Fox News
and I think according to Media Matters
it was like 3:17 p.m. ran a story about
Iran and though the threat from Iran
Iran's threat is growing it's so then
eight minutes later as a Matt girths was
pointing out on Twitter Trump tweets
this out in fact the president spent his
entire Sunday by the way sitting in his
big easy chair watching Fox News and
tweeting about it it was absolutely
disgusting but nonetheless he did it and
he said this he says that that will be
the end of Iran here's the thing we have
former US intelligence officials
military officials as well as former and
current military and intelligence
officials in Europe telling us that the
threat from Iran isn't real or at least
it hasn't increased which means there's
no imminent threat coming from Iran but
what's happening on the ground one is
you have john bolton in Donald Trump's
ear Trump doesn't know any better so
Bolton is likely to get his war with
Iran that he has wanted since day one of
the Bush administration into Trump's not
smart enough to understand he is also
one of the people being manipulated Iran
does not pose any significant threat
today at least no more so than they had
years ago which is to say not very much
at all there's plenty of other countries
out there that probably pose a much
bigger threat to the United States
dates but some of those countries are
the ones goading us into attacking Iran
for example Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia
claimed recently that one of their oil
tankers several their oil tankers
actually had been sabotaged and they
weren't sure if it was Iran by the way
they weren't able to conclusively prove
that Iran did this but they've got their
suspicions and they're also warning us
that you guys have tankers over there
near Iran and they may sabotage those so
what do we do in response we send our
aircraft carriers over there we start
with these flyover missions and what
that does is that is trying to goad Iran
into attacking us we're tempting them
we're daring them and why are we doing
that because it's worked out pretty well
for us in the past Libya in the 1980s we
did the same thing we flew our planes
over we issued these threats but we
weren't actually going to attack until
they attacked us and then they did and
then we did happened in Middle East in
the early 90s and now we're trying to
get it to happen again
we're sitting there essentially sending
our troops out there as bait
to see if Iran's gonna bite leaving our
tankers over there as bait to see if
Iran's going to attack them
that's this administration's plan and
the second something happens whether or
not they can even prove it's Iran there
it goes because Trump himself has
admitted that if they attack us that's
going to be the end of them and it's
also ironic because I'm pretty sure we
heard those same arguments before the
Iraq war yeah this would be a quick war
in and out real quick you wait in the
car
Tom cotton the Republican senator who
helped trash the Iran deer deal said
last week you know this would be just a
couple of days we'd be in and out we'd
be done we could defeat Iran never hear
from them again that never works that
never happens but that's how Republicans
think foreign policy works
you could follow me on twitter at fair
and balanced I am fair and cousins in
for David Pakman we'll be right back
today's program is sponsored partially
by zip recruiter I've talked people know
especially bonus show viewers I've
talked about the trials and tribulations
of hiring good people on the David
Pakman show we have a really great team
right now but hiring is difficult it
takes a long time you sometimes get too
many applicants or not enough qualified
ones or the wrong applicants but there's
one place where you can go we're hiring
is simple fast and smart and a place
where growing businesses can get
connected quickly to qualified
candidates and that is zip recruiter
dot-com / Pakman zip recruiter sends
your job to over a hundred of the
Internet's leading job boards they also
have powerful matching technology where
they will scan thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
for your job and it will invite them to
apply as the applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one spotlights
top candidates so you don't miss great
matches and it is so effective
zip recruiter is that four out of five
employers who post a job on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the website within the first day
and right now david pakman show viewers
and listeners can try zip recruiter for
free at recruiter dot-com slash Pakman
that's zip recruiter dot-com /pa que ma
N one more time
zip recruiter dot-com slash Pakman it's
the smartest way to hire